hello welcome to this video this is a
new five-minute game international
master who is that I don't know hey
sorry ma sorry Medina ok let's go here
don't play that line too often but some
variety is in order ok that's a very
early p5 normally not considered to be
good with the night being still odd be
one alright you rarely combined be five
min Bishop g4 does as well ok and
somewhat surprising choices here by my
opponent so let's see how to do that
just lightly to maybe ok i can go queen
a for one night be 352 ok let's flick
that in yeah I guess Queen a for right
create form oh I'm not quite sure how to
do that
now maybe still this
one problem of leg that is that a six
born noisy playing something drastic now
e5 and nope
if I have no i don't know i mean yes to
do something account just a stick around
and play passive moves and okay you
think you can he thinks he can't do that
I don't believe it this should be pretty
awful for black it doesn't have any
counter play was he going for something
crazy was g five or so I just need Roxy
to look see one and that's basically
game over as he cannot fight for the C
file and cover a six everything at once
okay he is doing something yeah question
is what exactly is it doing it so I
can't do this maybe just take Quincy
form it's a bit and playing it simple
but it's not bad
it's important to you that my bishop is
not bad at all on d too I mean it's not
beautiful but it added a text before
porn and this is very important black
has huge problems in coordinating these
pieces let's see how to do that should i
do g4 yeah I think I should if I get the
opportunity maybe f5 and then Bishop
over yeah okay I'll do that that is not
exactly great to put the bishop over to
g3 but maybe that's something I can do
later I played that too quickly that
move
hmm yeah so I don't mind mind that trade
I'm not quite sure if I should do it
though oxy it is also pretty good skip
and pinned you cannot go Rupe the eight
I mean okay that would give up the porn
on before immediately and what exactly
is this move now that is this move okay
now i'm trying to get the bishop over
now we can never move the b8 night like
that okay okay okay so this is coming
over to g3
so much for my bad bishop the thing is
how do we actually win this game at the
end i wonder if i should trade one rukon
not really unsure let's do that I mean I
don't want to lose on time again and
from a position where opponent is
already basically dead
k okay seven and how to do that I bishop
t6 as possible now it's not looking so
logical to treat this but i'm getting at
his pawns ultimately if it takes it i
just windy five outright my ideas Bishop
c5
okay not completely sure about a night
c550 twins or not takes rook cheeks not
quite sure about this it's difficult to
get my my book back into the game if I
don't do it like him he has a hard time
to activate his rook as I then we just
march the sea porn and they have kings
it will be three it should be reasonably
easy to to win so bring the king over ya
know c6
check check if I go up look you one is
it easier to go back actually it's
probably easier check
check there first time morning jack
check there first and then here 47 where
it looks good enough
check check check check check black
forfeits on time okay so he never he
never went for any kind of play that
that would set up with b5 and Bishop g4
strategically dubious anyway and he
never tried to somehow justify it here
black has to be he had black heads to do
something he cannot just stick around
otherwise he is strategically crushed
with them with a bad situation on the
queenside he has to do something
something directly let's say and so he
never did he never did um so this this I
can go afore he has an interesting
suggestion by the engine but i want to
check business things that he could have
done i think here he has to go e five I
mean absolutely only move and then the
situation isn't clear at all if he does
that and I probably my right the the
proper refutation of it said I probably
would have been with efore but I mean he
has to do this now if he doesn't he's a
new trouble something like this is this
is just okay for him I think yeah G
takes is interesting but I wanted to
play it simple this this and now he has
to do something if I I don't know after
that this is just a very bad position
just bad I'm 34 here here and yeah the
thing is I just have a very simple plan
rook see to look see one route c6 and he
can resign the game almost and I don't
know what he's supposed to do to prevent
it the engine finally enough suggestion
I txt 292 night
to something like this g6 this and then
back yeah okay well this is what you
have to do but if this is what you have
to do it's not great yeah okay this is
what you did and I just went well for
this kind of thing this is the easiest
way to play if he protects this now here
man I have a five or queen c6 it's not
so strong and that's very strong
actually too much hanging so this yeah
and this is a fantastic position I've
got the C file permanently and this f5
is this is quite ambitious but I think
it's an interesting way to play trying
to get that Ted Bishop into the game our
cage ATA was already crushing for Brooke
1c8 okay I missed that one that's true I
was just happy that I got my bishop
around and get that idea in but I mean
it's just not another position that
black can play and so I probably could
have won this a little bit quicker but
check it was I in any check any danger
of getting screwed up okay I'm happy
with that the the reason by the way why
b5 and bishops you form is not a good
combination yes that when you go be five
you always have the light squares
weakened yeah c6 and b7 in particular
those are weak and if you play b5 you
normally want the bishop there on b7 I
mean there are exceptions to that but
they are rare and in those kind of
situations very often White has a knight
on c3 already which is a difference
because after 93a for ya if you picture
that night c 3 a 4 then be four is
coming with the tempo and i have to put
the bishop somewhere i don't necessarily
want it to the night somewhere where I
don't necessarily want it to be often do
you have something like Knights
three i can put this hour i mean it's
not good yet because i will show you
this this and quite often the night ends
up on b3 yeah in 1 2 3 4 moves and in
the in the situation in the game it
actually ended up there two moves this
is a difference and it all adds up a
little bit however the real reason why
this is not good the way it went was
that i could have gone before here
that's a really strong move I didn't
think about it because I was so focused
on the queenside hear something like
that looks really promising for white no
blacks position is not very luck what he
needed and I'm just quicker than in
development some already pretty nice for
white okay thanks for watching